What is going on everyone? Welcome back
to another little bonus video for the
week. In today's video, we're going to
be simplifying payouts with basic
thinking in psychology. Let's get right
into it.
Before we get started, I want to add
that we just had a phenomenal first week
of 2026. I racked in 7,500 personal
payouts and the community came in with
$8,000 in the first trading day of 2026.
If you want to join or take part in
that, the link will be in the
description.
If you want to start getting consistent
payouts, you need to pick the easiest
firms to get payouts with and scale from
there. The first one that we're going to
cover is going to be the Lucid 25K Pro
Test. Now, before we get started, I want
to emphasize that I am not affiliated
with any of these firms. I just
genuinely like the products they provide
and how easy it is to get a payout with
them. The Lucid 25K accounts are by far
the best in the industry for beginners.
Really, all Lucid accounts are fine,
mainly because of that one-time payment
you see here. It's a $72 onetime payment
for the 25K, but all their accounts have
a onetime payment. So, there's no rush
in passing the evaluation account. It's
a $0 activation fee, and it's only 3,350
from Eval to payout. 40% consistency and
funded. It keeps you honest. It is a
small draw down, but it keeps you from
hitting too big of days. And the payouts
process end day. That's probably the
biggest draw down of Lucid. If you
qualify for a payout at New York Open,
you have to wait all the way until 6
p.m. The payouts do hit in minutes and
they have reliable customer support.
Similar to Lucid is the Tradeify 50K
growth accounts. $95 monthly payment.
So, you are in a small rush trying to
pass the evaluation account, but it's a
$0 activation fee. 6,000 from EVEL to
payout, 35% consistency. Payout process
is at the end of the day, same as Lucid,
and the highest payments take about nine
hours. The reason these two accounts are
the top two in the industry for me
personally is because
they're just incredibly easy to get a
payout from.
Probably some of the smallest Eval to
pay out in terms of what you have to
make dollar-wise, especially this Lucid
25K account. If you are struggling to
get payouts, if you're struggling to
pass evaluations, it's $1,250 to pass
the evaluation on these accounts. And
then it's 2,100 to get your first payout
of $1,000.
That should fund any of the remaining
payouts that you get from whatever other
prop you want to go with. And once you
do start getting payouts in, like I'm
doing the Apex 25K trade of eight
accounts, you can copy trade 20 of
these. So, I don't have any of the
payout features on here because I
haven't gotten a payout from them yet.
It's $19 per month depending on what
sale you get. 90% off, 80% off, 65 or an
$85 activation fee, so it's still less
than $100 and it's 3,100 from Eval the
payout.
You need to be trading micros on these
accounts. Take your time with them. copy
trade and
you either hit a $50 to $150 loss or you
hit a $50 to $150 gain. It's not
exciting, but scaled over multiple
accounts, 2530 funded accounts, that $50
trade is going to turn into a $1,500 to
$2,000 day.
Now, we're going to cover what a easy
prop firm versus a difficult prop firm
is. Taking a look at the Lucid 25K Pro
test as opposed to everyone's favorite,
the top step 50K eval. It's $3,000 to
pass the 50K eval over two days, meaning
that you're going to have more exposure
to the market as opposed to 12250 to
pass it in one day with Lucid.
750 to get your first payout with
TopSep. It is less than the 2100 to get
a payout with Lucid, but we're going to
cover what that means here in a minute.
qualifying days on top $150 as opposed
to $50 on Lucid, meaning that you're not
going to have as much exposure to the
market in terms of size. And then the
one that gets a lot of backlash here is
the 45% profit split with Tops Up, which
is absolutely horrendous. This is for
your first payout. It does grow after
that, but 97% of traders that trade a
prop firm don't make it past their first
payout.
45%
comes down to the fact that you can only
take 50% of your profits from Topstep
and they take a 9010 split on that. So
making $1,000, you're only going to be
able to take $450 out. Let's say you do
qualify for your payout on TopSep as
opposed to Lucid, you're going to have
$1,000 in draw down left after you take
$1,000 payout. Whereas on top step, if
you take a payout when you hit $750,
you're going to have $375 in draw down
and you're only going to have a payout
of $340, which barely even covers that
account.
Now,
analyzing this in terms of the numbers,
you're obviously going to go with the
Lucid account.
analyzing in terms of what people push
online and what hey I'm gonna take a 5k
payout from top
you need to make 10,000 on that top step
account to make a max payout as opposed
to only needing to make $2100 on Lucid
that 1,000 that you have in draw down
you only need to make $1,000 to get
another $1,000 payout.
The next thing you need to do if you
want to make payouts easier on yourself
is simplify everything.
As you can see on my chart right now,
it's not really all that complex. We
have the previous days 50 and London 50
as well as the IB. That's it. I do have
volume bars in the bottom. I don't
really use those, so we can go ahead and
turn those off. This is a pretty simple
looking chart. There's nothing overly
complicated. There's no EMAs. There's no
lines that are going to skew what I'm
looking at. It simplifies everything in
my head. Along with that, what
absolutely everyone should be doing, and
this is a human psychology trait, is you
need to get any red off of your chart.
Red correlates directly to urgency and
increased heart rate. That's human
psychology. Now, going back to what your
chart should look like if you want to
make payouts easier on yourself, really
just make trading easier on yourself, is
you want to start with a naked chart.
You don't want to have anything on your
chart that is going to distract you from
what you should be looking at, which is
just the candlesticks.
From there, all I put on is my London
50, previous days 50. But whatever it is
that you use, let's say that you use
fair value gaps or inverse fair value
gaps, and you're just trading those, why
would you have EMAs on? Why would you
have previous days gaps? Why would you
have support resistance levels if you're
just trading one model?
have that one model be the only thing
that's on your chart. The more that
you're looking at, the more distracted
you're going to be from what you should
be trading or what is reliable for you
to trade, the worse off you are. Now, if
I just have my chart on and I only use
previous days 50 and then I go and draw
in my London 50, it's clear and concise
where I should be looking, what I want
to be looking at for entries. For
today's example, great entry off London
50. Now, if I had EMAs on, if I just go
and slap any random old EMA on here, if
I had EMAs on, yeah, they might help. We
had a few bounces off of them, but
that's four more lines on my chart. Now,
if I go and add the volume back in,
let's say I want to put in the expansion
levels with the IB trade. Although these
are although these are all things that
I'm going to use, it gets a little
chaotic on my chart. I can't really see
what's going on in terms of where the
candle closed. And even if I can,
subconsciously, there's going to be a
lot of distractions on my chart. So,
what you want to do is you want to The
last thing we're going to cover is going
to be some hard rules that will prevent
you from blowing accounts as well as
help you stack payouts over the long
term. The first one's going to be, and
this is especially important on Mondays,
no trading that first 15-minute opening
candle. There's no reason to trade that
first 15-minute candle because you have
everyone from Friday close, Saturday,
Sunday, all the way until Monday's open
that are eager to get back into the
market. They're doing it on the first
five minute candle, even the first
15-minute candle of Monday's open. Along
with that, you usually have 9:45 or
10:00 data. That 9:45 candle comes in
right after that first 15-minute candle
close. Obviously,
nine times out of 10, it's going to wick
you out if there is significant data
before making a move in the direction
that you wanted.
Next thing that we're going to want to
do is make sure that you're on a higher
time frame chart. The lower down you go,
the faster the candles are going to
move, the more inclined you're going to
be to have a raised heart rate, which
directly correlates to poor decision-
making.
15 minute time frame is where I found
most of my comfort. Five minute time
frame works for a lot of people as well.
You want to use a time frame that aligns
with what your trading strategy is. If
you're just looking at the chart on the
one minute time frame for no reason,
again, you're going to have an increased
heart rate because the candles are
moving faster. You're going to want to
chase more. You're going to want to get
more plays. Just not not a good mixture.
And this one has probably helped
everyone that I've spoken with is just
sizing down. There is no reason for you
to go into a trade with 2NQ on 150K
account. You're risking $500, $1,000.
That only correlates to
a what 12.5 point risk.
that stock or that holding or that
futures asset, it's probably going to
wick you out before it makes the move
that you want it to. If your stop is
that close,
size down and scale that horizontally,
not vertically. You don't want to scale
per account. Target those two, three,
four, $5,000 days. I am the best trader
alive. You want to target
20 to 30 accounts making a single 2 M
and Q, 3 M andNQ, 4 M andq is probably
the max that I would go on those
accounts and that will allow you to make
more mistakes which those mistakes
correlate directly to learning events,
learning opportunities.
If you are consistently trading large
size for whatever reason it might be,
that size is going to correlate to more
losses, which correlates to more blown
accounts.
Now, the reason being is
taking a $500 loss, let's say, off of a
trade that then goes and hits your TP.
You're going to be in a terrible mental
state from that. Let's say I wanted to
long off of London 50 right here, 61762.
My stop loss was 13 points, 12 and a
half points. I just lost $500. And now
if I had been in the trade, and
everyone's done this. Uh, if I had held
it, I'd be up 6,000 right now, or I'd be
up 600 right now, or I'd be up x amount
right now. If I held it, I'd be up this
much.
That comes from having a stop loss that
is too tight
or being unlucky on a trade. More often
than not, it comes from the stop being
too tight because you're risking too
much on that trade. Size down. Take the
same setups. Copy trade those setups
over multiple accounts. If you're doing
two and Q on, let's say a 50k account,
you have $2,000 in draw down. Your risk
is, let's say, $200.
It's going to take you 10 consecutive
losing trades
with a 50 point stop loss on those
trades for 2 M and Q, which 50 points is
a lot.
10 consecutive losing trades before you
blow that account.
I don't know about you, but I haven't
really gone on a 10 losing streak very
often.
Maybe I lose five in a row and then I I
win a couple in a row, lose another five
in a row, win a couple in a row. The
more exposure you have, the more
learning opportunities you have, the
fewer mistakes you're going to make over
the long run. That's how you develop.
That's how you become a better trader,
better in any aspect, whatever it might
be. Mistakes lead to learning events.
Now, if you're just taking trades that I
just risked 500, it only dropped 12
points. Now, I'm stopped out, but it
ended up going the direction I wanted
to. you're going to blow the account in
two, three, four trades, or you're just
going to blow the account because you
revenge trade after you take that loss.
You're not going to learn anything from
that. You're going to go and trade the
following account the same exact way,
the next account, the same exact way,
and so on and so forth. You're not going
to improve. You're just going to
continue to churn accounts.
Size down. No trading on volatile
candles. Really, just the first
15-minute candle. No trading on news
candles as well. I should add that in.
And then the last one is be able to lock
out, be able to close the tab, be able
to do end your trading session for the
day. If you see a big old trend day like
this, like we had on Friday, January
2nd, I made $80 on my funded account or
$50 in my funded account. I missed the
potential to make $1,000 more because we
dropped 800 points. But would I have
caught that or would I have blown my
account in the meantime trying to call
the bottom or continuing to short and
catching this 150 point candle back up.
Be happy with what you're making and
move on to the following trading day.
Trade the setups that are within your
parameters. No need to trade setups that
are outside of your parameters.
And that's it. If you guys enjoyed this
video, let me know. I will make another
video like this for prop firm reviews
coming up here soon. Uh, and then we'll
have another video for the IB strategy
this week. See you guys later.